It's really funny,
we're starting to see
so many more titles coming in
that are "Creative Director"
or "Director of Innovation,"
and I feel like our generation
is going to, kind of, see past that
and understand that every single employee
needs to have creativity
in everything that they do everyday,
that's this element of our work
that's been lost over the past 20 years,
and I think it's going to get integrated back in.
I don't know how to say this any other way,
but I hope every company around the world
gets rid of their HR departments
because it ruins communication, and
I'll start over and I'll try to think of an actual job,
but maybe you guys can help me.
What's a job that's like anti-HR?
Is there a job that's like anti-HR?
Ah, I don't know,
like master chopper,
like guillotine guy,
like "And you're done, like, leave."
I don't know of the anti-HR job.
Probably the easiest answer would be
the jack-of-all-trades guy.
Every company sort of has someone
in their company that they go to
for matters that there is no title for,
whether it's, "I have a communication issue,"
or "I don't like the project I'm on right now."
And I feel like that sort of jack-of-all-trades job
has yet to really define itself,
but it will,
and when we know it, we'll see it.
Click any of these fortune cookies
to see your questions and follow-up questions explored.
Click this cookie to return to the intro video
and see what this series is all about,
or click this cookie to suggest
alternative questions,
participants,
or career paths
for future videos.